the medium is a psychological horror
game with a considerable amount of the
game focused on the story the game is
full of story and it's only right to
make a video talking about that story
and this video will not only cover that
but also the ending of the game and what
it means as well as the loads of
additional items we find from postcards
to notes explaining characters like
francis the maw richard and many others
as always spoiler warning ahead as the
whole game will be spoiled especially
the ending as we discuss that very early
in the game to make sense of the whole
timeline so beat it and come back
with that out of the way welcome to the
medium story explained
so this game's story is all over the
place so the says that the story is
there but it's not really discovered in
a linear way we're just picking up the
pieces as we go along and are basically
forced to put them together which is not
a bad thing it just may confuse some
people so let's start as slow as we
possibly can and explain marianne and
what she is that being a medium mediums
are people with special powers they're
able to peer into the spirit realm while
also existing in the irregular realm or
as the game calls it the material realm
which i'll be referring it to is that
for the rest of the video as marianne
says herself she's able to interact and
see into both worlds at the same time
that she can be affected in both realms
we could see this in game as she can be
attacked by the boss that only exists in
the spirit realm yet take damage and die
in the material one as a medium marianne
helps the souls and spirits of the world
pass on so they're not stuck here she
can also use her powers like spirit
blast
and insight to aid in this it's not
confirmed that's actually her true
purpose as a medium but it's what she
does with her powers regardless
very early in the intro we find out that
marianne is an orphan well at least she
was made to believe that we see marianne
in possibly her mid-20s throughout the
game but there is a lot of stuff that
happens before we even start the game
that we uncover as we play
marianne at the beginning of the game
works at the funeral home with her
foster parent jack
sadly he passed away a couple days ago
so we have to take care of the usual
funeral home procedures of dressing up
the dead and making sure they look
presentable in the casket
after some time she gets a call from a
man only known as thomas saying a
familiar line to her which piques her
interest enough to go to the location he
specified which is nero resort this is
then where the real story of the game
begins so now the intro and the basics
are covered let's go over everything
before this point
towards the end of the game we
investigate the red house where tons of
her backstory is shown
marianne's family consists of lillian
and thomas their mother existed but she
passed away
according to marianne both her parents
died in a car crash and she was the only
survivor but miriam was lied to as she
wasn't the only survivor only her mom
died
lily for some time blamed marianne for
the death of her mom we can see this in
thomas's note titled demons
in the game we fight two large creatures
the child leader and the hound these are
the physical manifestations of the
person in the spirit realm both the
hound and the child
talk like they are the person that we
uncover the hound is within henry's
memories and the hound when we meet him
in the spirit realm talks like he is
henry
mentioning how the damage was already
done and that he was already dead that
thomas made sure of that referencing
the fight the two had prior it could
also be argued that the creature's other
negative actions thoughts and emotions
all stored up in one place and once
again physically manifested into some
creature the maw is lily's manifestation
which is why they all exist in the
spirit realm except for the mall where
he can occasionally transcend the
dimensional barrier this is most likely
due to lilly setting them off free which
we will discuss soon thomas is
marianne's father and he was the one who
gave us the call in the intro of the
game and the one we play throughout the
game as well
thomas also has the same power as
marianne as we discovered that he passed
down this power to both the sisters when
they were born
with the quick intros of both thomas and
lily out of the way let's delve more
into them and what exactly is going on
with lily her story starts at the
beginning with sadness
sadness lily and lillian are all the
same person just remember that as we
continue this video sadness is only in
the spirit realm as we see this numerous
times and she instructs us to find a man
named richard even though we want thomas
but richard's memories and the items we
find on the way help us to piece
together sadnesses well
sadness from the various insights we see
two other characters hannah and bernard
we know these are relevant to sadness
because we see the butterflies
instructing us where to go which is
sadness showing us the situations
involving her these insights play like a
broken up story lily hannah and bernard
are playing hide and seek lou is trying
to find them and hannah is hiding with
bernard but she has a plan to get back
at her we could see lily talking to
herself and hannah calling her a weirdo
for it this is because she's talking
with her spirit form we see the same
thing with thomas in the first memory
until we realize that he isn't just
talking to himself he's talking to his
spirit form and since no one else can
see the spirit form it looks like he's
rambling to himself this is the exact
same situation for lily even in the note
aqua girl which is written by ursula the
nurse of richard we see that she was
asked to watch over lily and that she
seems like a nice girl and likes to talk
to her imaginary friends and it almost
sounds like two people are talking and
there's a picture of most likely an
artist's representation of this
engagement of lilly having another side
to her that's spirit form lily during
her hide-and-seek game enters a dark
room and can't see anyone is starting to
become a little
frightened hannah is still enacting her
plan but bernard is still against the
plan he feels bad for her we then see
the trail lead us to a locker with some
drawings and a cat figurine
this like many things in this game are
confirmed to us but we can see that it
was heavily implied that hannah jumped
lily and locked her in the locker we
then meet sadness again and she talks
about richard she seems clearly
distressed about him as she runs away
out of fear after she thought about
richard again
richard is a painter and the teacher of
the art class at niwa lily ended up
joining the class but wanted to play
with her other friends instead
possibly referring to her spirit form
but thomas made it clear to richard that
she doesn't do that
lily is too young to understand the
spirit realm and what it can really do
so it's best not to bring it up to her
and even if we did bring it up to her
she wouldn't understand anyway we could
see that lily is also a gifted musician
too
and richard talks about him reminiscing
of the good times in his life when he
hears this melody of hers a foreshadow
to a future memory diver richard which
is quite interesting and well placed
we can then see a memory of richard
painting lily and then she reminds him
of a girl he liked it's not named but
it's most likely rose the girl he met
when he was young richard in another
memory is crying and feeling sad over
doing something this is linked to the
sketchbook thomas finds in richard's
room
it's unclear what's inside as we never
see for ourselves but my theory is that
richard either did something sexual with
her like drawing her in a sexual way or
maybe he hit her or maybe it's even a
combination of both as that sketchbook
seems to be very relevant as to why
thomas is angry
richard also brings up how he wanted to
die and that he didn't do it possibly
meaning that he was controlled to do it
so maybe it wasn't his fault technically
but rather something inside him like i
said it's just a theory so it's not
entirely concrete so i encourage you to
comment what you think happened
regardless it's clear that richard did
something that hurt her whether it was
physical or emotional we find out from
spirit thomas at the end of the game
that when richard had hurt her that
caused the maw to awaken and thomas's
note called a different kind of sickness
we see him document that lily isn't
physically ill but that something on
that day stirred something in her we
meet sadness again on the swingset and
come to the red house where we hear
about the burning of the red house we
see from thomas's second memory the red
house where lily lives was burned down
thanks to a man named henry who is
investigating thomas
lilly would have died if not for the mod
the maw has been in her head since the
incident with richard but he kept
growing stronger and stronger
at this point he enacted a deal if she
lets him out she'll be kept alive
marianne was also present at the house
and she barely survived too
when the house is on fire thomas hears a
voice and he calls out to bold the
sisters meaning marianne was present at
the house at the time
and lily even asks about her sister if
she'll be okay but the moth says don't
worry about her remember when she killed
your mom mary anne after the burning of
the house was hospitalized and put in a
coma this is why she doesn't remember
anything about her childhood and why she
doesn't remember lily or thomas right
away despite them being her family
lilly's story ends here for right now as
thomas is now involved too
thomas as we said is the father of both
marianne and lily thomas also has a ton
of notes labeled under troubled man's
notes in the memos thomas was doing
something and tried to keep it hidden
from the various notes which talk about
the less obvious places at neva in the
underground nazi bunker he found behind
the woods he was using the resort as a
front to focus on his work which would
end up catching the eye of an
investigator thomas was the manager of
the niwa resort and even offered to
extend a helping hand to richard thomas
knew richard
when thomas was a little boy but when he
was older at the resort lots of time
thomas would explain his dream world as
he called it
richard would then paint what he
envisioned we can assume that it was
just thomas talking about the spirit
realm which is why richard talked about
his descriptions of the place being so
thorough
almost as if he was there which he
actually was it's hard to explain
something like the spear realm without
being looked at as crazy so thomas used
it as a therapy session almost while
richard just painted
richard was given a place to stay at the
resort thanks to thomas which is how he
ended up here since he was an entrusted
friend he was tasked with watching over
lily which we previously discussed and
we know that at some point richard would
end up hurting her in some way this
caused him to lash out at richard i'll
delve more into richard and his
backstory a bit more later but once the
burning of the red house occurred he
went into the bunker and hid lily away
from the outside world thomas left
marianne at the hospital so that she
could have a normal life away from the
maw and lily while he tried to figure
out how to stop it
that's why in thomas's room a business
card for jack the foster parent to
marianne is in there he contacted him so
that she would have someone to raise her
the don't written on the card maybe him
forcing himself not to call jack and ask
about marianne as it would just ruin
everything he did for her safety as we
know during the burning of the house the
maw was let free although during his
research thomas wanted to figure out how
to be left alone
or at least in his case separate the
spirit realm from him in countless notes
he talks about just wanting to be alone
and wants nothing to do with the spirit
realm that he just wants to be a father
and nothing else
that's why salt is in his office in the
beginning of the game along with the
burn marks on the broken glass he was
experimenting with different ingredients
to see what worked and then he finally
discovered that it was salt this is why
lily's room is covered in salt in the
bunker and there's an iv bag of salt in
her room
he wanted to separate them off from her
so he lined her room with salt and
injected salt into her because the maw
was becoming too powerful now that he
was free referencing his other notes
thomas noticed that the maw became even
stronger saying that he was hearing it
in his dreams and even in his mind
thomas even thought about the last case
scenario of killing lily but as a father
he simply couldn't do that
thomas after the massacre and the
abandoning of the resort would still use
the place as his office for his test
experiments as we see a recently written
to-do list as well as the energy of his
presence from the phone meaning he
called us in the intro from this phone
in the back room is a hidden away area
he was developing photos here possibly
to help with research but he also took a
picture of marianne which we see in the
slideshow there's even a note about this
called
keeping distance thomas didn't want to
leave her at the hospital but he also
didn't want his daughter to be involved
in this mess but he knew it was only a
matter of time until she figured it out
thomas was going to let marianne live
her life thinking she was the only one
with these mysterious powers but thomas
used his last resort of calling marianne
at the intro as it got too strong for
him to handle and knew that she could
deal with it on her own there's also him
being a father which is
understandable why he has a picture of
her he hasn't seen her for years and he
wanted at least something of hers to
look at as he clearly misses her that
recently written to-do list in his
office shows that he is still trying to
help lily fully separate from the moss
so he can kill it
yes the maw has broken free but he has
broken free of her restraints on him but
he's still connected to her because it's
her negative feelings manifested all in
one place like we said before that's why
if he can break this link with the maw
he will truly die
which makes sense why he comes back
after killing it so many times we see
throughout the game i want to take this
moment to talk about richard francis and
henry so that we can truly understand
everybody else's stories as they're what
ties everything together i thought it
would be appropriate now and not before
as it would have just been too much
information all at one time we see a
couple memories of richard before and
after his meeting with thomas in the
beginning he was talking with a nurse
named ursula he was being sweet with her
giving her flowers and such richard
would ultimately send her a letter
explaining that they are nothing more
than friends as he is a damaged man
richard most likely thinks that anyone
he loves betrays him or dies and he
doesn't want that with ursula
the previous line will make sense in a
moment but we can see that ursula was
not happy about this as she has an empty
pill bottle on a sink and a drawing
nearby made by sadness of her crying
when we confront richard's thomas we go
into his mind and see his past all of
richard's memories were of his childhood
richard is old when we see him in the
memories so that means as a kid he was
somewhere around the 1940s
this is solidified with the upcoming
memories we see richard's father left at
a young age to go fight in the polish
army
in the office space we get a broken up
passage of genesis 3 19. this passage is
the conclusion to adam's sins by god
saying that you were born from dust and
that you will return to dust and that he
will not work with purpose or meaning
only stress and frustration
we find the last note from the minister
of military affairs saying that
richard's father died this is most
likely the fight between germany and
poland during world war ii
in which poland lost then gets shoved
into another memory of a maze richard is
a child talking to a girl named rose
rose gives him something that is
supposed to be kept safe richard's mom
was lonely due to the loss of her
husband so she ended up finding another
lover this father however was not as
cheerful it's implied that he was
physically abusive to richard as a kid
as we walk down the hall where richard
attempts to save his mother from his
stepfather
and it's possible that she was a being
abused too but it doesn't seem to have
worked as we don't hear richard again
after his initial lines until we walk in
and hear her scream more while richard
berates himself saying that he couldn't
even protect himself
or his mom he meets with rose one more
time and is clearly displaying
anger towards her because of his
stepfather's actions and he's taking it
out on her later we hear his stepfather
yell in pain
an interesting twist from what we
previously heard as you explore the
attic we hear his stepfather repeat some
words
link this with the noose at the end and
it seems like he was hung which is nice
but it comes as bittersweet
as when richard goes to the maze rose is
not there but the item she gave richard
to keep safe is fully revealed to be a
star of david
rose was jewish for a quick recap
history lesson one of the biggest
tragedies of the world was the holocaust
where germany
exterminated millions of jews not
everyone in germany or the germany
conquered countries like poland agreed
with this viewpoint so some took the
hiding jewish people in their homes the
nazi party discovered this was happening
and sent people to investigate the
houses and said that any jews or people
who helped jews would be put to death
and this is what happened to richard's
stepfather it's unclear how all this
happened though as it seems implied that
rose did not live with richard as if
they would have lived together they
would have just met in the house and not
some random maze far away
it seems that the mother twisted the
word so that she could get the
stepfather in trouble without
incriminating herself since she was in a
relationship with him so now richard is
all alone in the world he doesn't have a
father anymore he has no best friend and
he still has a mother but she also
indirectly killed his only friend this
trauma could explain why he hurt lily
rose and lily do have similar names
related to flowers and richard mentions
that she reminds her of someone he knew
as a kid and maybe those awful memories
flooded back into his mind and he hurt
lily next to the area back as mary anne
we see a police chief questioning thomas
thomas made it seem like he was upset
that his friend was possibly dead but
marian notices that he's lying
thomas almost killed richard with his
special powers but he was now in a
vegetative state
thomas would assign ursula as his nurse
so she got to see him and take care of
him as we see in one memory but due to
the mob breaking free and slaughtering
the hotel the mod
would make ursula the vessel being a
voice in her head and constantly
reminding her of her bad
thoughts ursula was also prescribed
pills for her hysteria and insomnia so
she most likely didn't take those which
caused her to go insane this ends with
ursula talking to richard and stabbing
him repeatedly even though he can't
speak he's still alive and can feel
every time she stabs him this is the
start of the massacre francis was the
groundskeeper of the resort he made tons
of postcards we could find that he was
going to send to his family but he never
had the courage to for some reason they
sounded like fairly normal talking about
his life at the resort until they start
to take a turn the postcards titled a
scenic view and won't stop prove this
one talking about the residents how
they're nice nice and dead
and at the end of the other where he
says he just wishes it was quiet and why
it won't stop talking the key word is
it it spirals further into madness when
we meet francis in person and he talks
about him being at fault for killing
everyone that they are dead because of
him and the postcard next to him talks
about him
letting her see the light this is backed
up by the cards near the area which talk
about the voices he hears and that he
wants lily to see the outside world it's
possible it was the maw influencing him
francis inside his tent however
is dead and we can't talk to him anymore
what we can gather the red house burned
in the back of the resort but the resort
was still operational it wasn't until
francis noticed lily in the bunker and
let her out that the law regained his
freedom and thanks to their
not being salt anywhere outside the
bunker the massacre happened this caused
the resort to shut down
francis was somehow alive and then died
soon after he looks long dead before we
hear his last words it couldn't have
been at that very moment he said those
considering there's a bag over his head
and that the life looks sucked out of
him like the deers nearby
he was probably dead for quite a bit of
time but not as long as the residents in
the resort he most likely stayed to
think about what he had done
or due to the maw being in his head
making him go crazy henry is our last
side character and he shows up quite
early as he's the unidentified man on
the phones we hear the beginning phone
calls we see don't explain too much
just updates to his superiors saying
he's working on it and that new details
have emerged but never explain what
those details are
we need a lot more info when we make it
to thomas's garage he seems to be
questioning francis richard and lily
about thomas's whereabouts saying that
he needed him for something
on a recorder henry talks about the
gemini case and that he's proceeding
with the investigation into thomas but
he may have suspected him thomas is
trying to break into henry's suitcase
and find some classified files and that
he's part of the security service henry
knows a lot of thomas already
like his birthplace of warsaw and how
the nazis would have killed him but they
harnessed his power as he calls it
but because germany lost in world war ii
in the cause of the cold war time period
russia was in control of poland for some
time and arrested thomas to figure out
why he was so special
after they ran tons of experiments on
him he would eventually escape at the
age of 18 after killing some scientists
and was free from their rule over him
until he used his powers again
on richard henry was sent to investigate
thomas's powers this would explain why
thomas was hiding or mentioning the less
obvious places of the resort and the
bunker he was hiding from the people he
escaped from
he knocks him out and attempts to get
him to talk by burning down the red
house this is further shown in memories
after this when we play as marian again
and hear henry dumping gasoline
everywhere when he awakes he sees the
house on fire and he uses his powers on
henry
as spirit thomas we can go through his
mind and uncover more details into the
gemini case we see in a film reel inside
that henry was investigating jacob wilke
for a recent meat scandal and that he
was charged for corruption and the theft
of high quality meat which he replaced
with lesser quality ones at the same
price but henry and him share the same
last name this is henry's father
it seems he ratted out his own father
for his mistreatment and abuse when he
was a butcher and henry was forced to
work with him at the shop because of
these past actions he sold him out he
wasn't the only one to be caught however
others involved were also apprehended
and according to the newspaper will most
likely be hanged for it the next reel is
from his superior about a job which
seems to be top priority and very
classified this is the start of the
investigation or the gemini case
henry's to consult with richard which we
know he does from the insights we saw
earlier and investigate a person of
interest at the niwa resort we know as
thomas
the note strongly recommends that he
acquaints himself with the soviet
doctor's notes that were recorded in
1950 which most likely relates to thomas
and his powers it's not confirmed that
it was thomas but considering he was
held by the soviet union around this
time and he has these superpowers that
are really rare it was most likely him
some of it is classified but it's clear
they're coming up with some interesting
theories
in session 42 they're gaining more info
on thomas and how he's able to talk to
his spirit form and that this may have
been a result of a near-death experience
thomas seemed to put someone in a
vegetative state in session 43 which
would make sense why they seeked out
richard as the same thing happened to
him
session 44 talks about how they upped
security in the dosages to keep
him secure as he's very dangerous that
clearly didn't work as we know that he
breaks out but
we get a bit more info on henry once
again as it plays audio of him leaving
suddenly his wife
seems unfazed by the news and his son is
upset that he's leaving as he doesn't
like it when he leaves
when spirit thomas makes it to kid henry
he's caught by the monster called the
hound which we've been seeing quite a
bit in our time in his mind and he
becomes trapped the hound mentions that
there is no unhappy child or guilty
conscience like he thought he would be
finding here
just the hound after this memory
sequence thomas and henry get into a
fight and thomas ends up winning
after the memory marian wakes up and
sees the hound thankfully she beats him
and he is gone
the part with the hound is interesting
however spirit thomas at the end of the
game said he was trapped in there with
the hound until we eliminated him this
is around the time of the burning house
so the bunker
massacre and the salt pouring hasn't
happened yet this may partially relate
to what spirit thomas was saying to
mariana about not feeling regular
thomas's presence anymore but that could
also relate to the after credits ending
too regardless thomas and the material
world was free from spirit thomas thanks
to the salt and spirit thomas was
trapped in the hound's cage for years
until we came along and freed him
so that was quite a bit of info we
talked about before we bring up the
ending let's quickly recap what we know
so far
it won't be as detailed as the previous
parts of this video it'll be very simple
but it's just enough to walk away from
the video at least saying that you
understand the story at its most basic
level
thomas as a kid was born with special
powers when he was a kid he was
experimented on but later would break
free of the soviet doctors who kept him
locked away
he ended up staying in the niwa resort
and used it as a front so he could hide
from his captors and continue
researching the spirit realm on his own
he would later have two daughters lily
and marianne with his wife who would die
very early into their lives
thanks to thomas power he passed them
down to his daughters thomas needed help
watching over his daughters and their
power so he hired his old friend richard
to help until richard hurt lily and
using his powers he put him in a
vegetative state because of this a
little while later the investigator
known as henry would find him and
interrogate him about his powers
to get him to speak he burned down the
house in the house was marianne and lily
lily was saved by the maw a spiritual
being that had been hibernating in her
since her interaction with richard he
isn't a friendly being however as he
wanted to get out and taste death so
they formed a deal to let the mob break
free
and she gets to live she agreed with the
maw aryan also lived the fire too she
would then be sent to a hospital and be
put in a coma
after talking with his daughter thomas
discovered the voice in her head is now
free and could cause him danger
this couple with the government knowing
of thomas's location hidden a bunker
away from the outside world he also cut
all contact from his daughter marianne
so that she can have a normal life away
from everything that has happened and
hope she won't seek him out he
discovered that salt was the key
ingredient in making the spirit room go
away which he originally used to keep
that side of him away so he could feel
normal again but eventually when lily
became unstable from what richard did
he used the salt on her too this is
further proved by the salt on the walls
and the iv bag would salt in it this
kept the moss secure for some time until
the groundskeeper francis let her out
francis felt bad that she was there all
the time and wanted her to see the
outside world for a little bit
but this would be problematic as this
caused the maw to break free once more
causing the infamous niwa massacre
francis blames himself for the whole
incident and is ashamed of it
he would eventually succumb to the maw's
power and die like the others
we as marianne are called by thomas who
call this as a last resort to help and
after going through the whole resort we
meet with spirit thomas and the bunker
who mentions that lily is still alive
and that she can be helped
for the ending we meet with lily on the
pier and the two sisters reunite and
talk as they haven't since they were
kids
lily explains the massacre and that she
caused it the maw was created by her
lily explains that all her father's
attempts to rid them off her failed and
that the dream marianne was having which
is thomas killing lily on the pier was
something she
wanted to happen she wants to die as
that's the only way this ends we meet
with them all once more the mog gives
away his plan however he doesn't need
lily anymore he only wants marianne now
marianne then has the great idea to kill
herself if lily dies the maw may
disappear but who knows if it won't come
back and take marianne over the same way
it did lily but if marianne was gone the
maul would have no one else to use and
can enact any more bloodshed
a gunshot is heard and it's unclear who
dies our after credits cutscene comes in
with a mysterious person picking up a
watch in the spirit realm
this is thomas not only can we save this
from his identifiable black gloves but
it's the same watch from the first
memory the reason we can't find thomas
in game is because he's been in the
spirit realm from his research he must
have found a way to get inside the realm
the reasoning is unclear but it could be
linked to him finishing off the maw and
riding lily of her curse
he was probably unsure if he would
succeed in his mission to confront the
maw in the spirit room so just in case
he called marianne to help him as a
backup or he could already be trapped as
in the intro he talks about it being
dark and that the light is fading it's a
cool little cutscene that leaves
everyone wanting more this is either
going to be left up to interpretation
and stay this way or a dlc considering
the fact that only one of bloopers games
got dlc which is layers of fear it's
unlikely this is resolved there's always
the possibility of a sequel that picks
up from here but who knows for now it's
just going to be theory crafting and
speculation we now come to the end of
the video this is definitely one of the
hardest videos i've ever done
the story was scattered everywhere and
putting it together was quite tough but
i think it did a solid job retelling it
for those interested did you know that
the spirit realm was heavily influenced
by the polish artist bexinsky if you
want to see his art talked more in depth
i highly recommend the video called the
nightmare artist by in praise of shadows
here on youtube
i'll leave his link down below in the
description tell him i sent you in to
check out the game for himself with that
though thank you for joining me on this
journey through the story of the medium
like the video if you enjoyed and
subscribe for more lore content on other
games in the future
take care and goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye